good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy thursday hope
everyone's having an amazing day
here in new york it is blizzard season
it is so
snowy it's like so blown out behind us
it's been snowing all through the night
still snowing this morning it really is
a winter wonderland except it's nothing
like the hallmark movies because what
they don't show you in the hallmark
movies is the duty brown snow that
collects in the street
when you don't plow the streets mr mayor
where are the snowplows
yeah no these snowplows should be
working around the clock
and they're just not doing that well i
actually i do
love like a winter wonderland um in new
york because i don't really like leave
my house that much so
it's not like that much of an event in
convenience especially in covid
so i was just enjoying being all like
snuggled up on my bed like
that last night i was really enjoying it
this morning that was another story but
i've got my my
moon boots on my snow boots so i was
just tearing down the streets i've got
my snow boots on as well i had to
literally pull them out of the back of
my closet like could not find them but
i actually don't mind the snow boat look
no i love
my moon boots and i just got another
pair of moon boots that are like even
these ones are just like functional like
i actually wear them to go ski
and i don't care so much about them but
i just got like a chic pair of moon
boots that i'm really excited about
but shoon boots shoe boots but i've been
wearing moomoos since college i think
they're like the cutest boots i think so
too and this season they are the cutest
boots ever
but i'll be wearing them long and too
much
like i love them so much and they're so
functional like i
actually own snow boots and i'm always
so excited to wear them mine are from
ugg
and they are reasonably priced and i
think still really cute yeah they're
cute too
i wouldn't have snow boots if we never
like went to utah like i used
when it snows in new york like twice a
year you just figure it out like you
wear sandals and it just works that
would be me
if moon boots didn't exist right like i
only have snow boots because i love
moon boots so we've been here um in the
studio for about 20 minutes and you have
not said one word about my haircut well
because i noticed it on your instagram
yesterday and honestly i
i just haven't mentioned it because i
don't know how to tell you this
but you're triggered by it because
you're jealous i'm so jealous that's
good you know because i'm triggered by
your apartment
okay because i want an apartment that
nice and now you're triggered by my hair
because you want hair this night yeah no
like that's like my ideal haircut like
that's exactly what i would ask for when
i went like just like
layered well we go to the same
hairstylist mahogany so you could say
just give me the claudia yeah
this is actually like the rachel kind of
it's like layered but it's so much
longer than the region yeah but it's
like the same kind of aesthetic for my
certain hairline and i think we should
change it officially to the claudia
yeah we could yeah or we could just say
like keep it long with liars
along with layers but these are like you
know i'm very specific about my layers
because some people like the front
pieces like to go up to their nose
and because i have this like a really
terrible disease called fat face
um i cannot have the front pieces go
anywhere like higher
some pieces are short though yeah but
they're still they cannot go
yeah above my chin like that's
unacceptable so it's a whole like
mathematic we had to get like the
protractor it was like a whole thing but
we figured it out because of my very
serious illness it looks great i'm gonna
get a haircut in the new year and i'm
i'm so excited my hair is so long i can
do
anything like a haircut i can do
anything with my hair right now cause i
have so much like
length remember we're new to bob i know
one day i'm gonna go back to the bob
life
there's just nothing like a haircut to
give you like a renewed sense of self
100
a new outlook on life so what are you
looking like what are you seeing
in your new outlook so i'm saying that
things are you know still pretty much
the same
but i'm looking at it with fresh eyes
i'm sore from live method and when i
laugh my chest hurts
and it's like it feels like a pain that
should be concerning it's just so sad
that you're hanging out with the
funniest girl live
stop also it's coming from my right side
so like i'm not concerned and i know
it's like
it's soreness because i'm really sore
but it's like a new thing i guess we're
doing like too much
chest pains are never good we're doing
too much chest work man and so
it's really painful you're gonna be
brought as [ __ ] i'm going to be broad
yes
we have an amazing show for you guys
today of course the fast five two hours
of housewives last night
oc and salt lake city and i have a very
hot take did you watch oc
yeah i watched both i have a very hot
take i actually think that the oc
episode was better than the salt lake
city episode really
yeah i still liked the salt lake city
like ladies better than the vibe but in
terms of like drama
and movement and plot i actually like
thought the
oc episode was really super interesting
it was pretty interesting but i just
loved also watching salt lake city last
night as it snowed and there it's
sundance
and i'm just like this is the vibe i
gotta get to sundance
yeah i hate going to things where like
it's the thing and everyone's there
that's so funny we couldn't be more
different like i love that yeah no it's
like like coachella
i want to go to park city when no one's
there oh but i like when i can get a
reservation at any restaurant it's not
like everyone from hollywood is in town
it's like if i wanted to go to hollywood
i would i would take a flight to l.a
okay i feel that i do
and i like that as well like i actually
prefer to go to montauk in the winter as
opposed to the summer you know what i
mean yeah but that doesn't mean i'm
still not going to like the hot spot
weekends
in you know park city because i just
love to like flex and be a star [ __ ]
and i'm like such a social climber and
that's like where i thrive
yeah i know and i don't need it to be
like desolate but it's like i don't need
to go to montauk on july 4th
i can go the following weekend oh that's
so funny no i will go the following
weekend but then i also must be there
the weekend of like how is anyone gonna
know like i'm girl with no job you know
speaking of girl with no job we are now
super well not super close we're getting
closer to the release of my book a girl
with no job the crazy beautiful life of
an instagram thirst monster
it is available for pre-order if you go
to girlwithnojob.com
book very simple to remember all the
retailers are there plus all the
versions are available for pre-orders
that's audiobook
e-book and of course hardcover book um
and it's just a fabulous book there's
some fabulous blurbs on the back written
by
a couple fabulous people including my
sister jackie and if you want to support
jackie
buy this book if you want to support me
it would mean a lot to me guys
thank you you know this is why i did it
like for you you know
um yeah so girls no job.com book if
you're on my instagram live last night i
played a little game
where people were commenting page
numbers and then i would just find the
page and read the first sentence on the
page and i think it got everyone like i
think pre-sale numbers were
really up and if your question is should
i wait till the week of or should i
pre-order
either works as long as you're buying my
book but presale would be really helpful
so you can see i'm trying to get into
bookstores and more importantly airport
bookstores
and you need to have like high
concentration of order numbers in order
to do that so
girlwithnowjob.com book and i really you
can buy it from anywhere of course local
bookstores if you use
bookshop.com but if you're looking to
save some money this holiday season
amazon keeps putting my book on sale
like without my permission
so um it's good for you yeah competition
benefits the consumer
and you know there's a picture of the on
the back so on days like today when he's
not on the show like you could just look
at it
i couldn't bring him in today i no i
when i
i don't when i rolled up and i saw he
wasn't here i was like oh of course
no it's so cold he walked for 45 minutes
did not poop
and he came back freezing and like so
when he was laying in the living room
it's 79 degrees and he's just like
sweating
bullets bruno hasn't been outside in
like 24 hours now
it's so hard to be a dog mom when it
snows like we are just such an
underappreciated group of people i know
but then i saw like knowles was thriving
in the snow and i was like oh my
am i well i don't want to out knowles
but knowles
doesn't really go out you know oh yeah
she has like a nice little place that
she goes yeah that's true she doesn't go
to like salted streets and stuff no and
the salt is really scary it gets like
stuck in their paws
yeah theo was like limping yesterday
because there was a piece of salt
stuck between his paw pads like it was
so sad stop that's why he needs the
boots
lip no i know did you see those boots
nose was wearing yeah
really cute theo we've tried boots like
the balloon boots
and regular boots we're gonna just got a
pair of balloon boots and it's like
he has four legs like every time i have
to put on four shoes like it's insane
it's insane no okay i'm glad you feel
like they had like a little zipper hers
looked better
yeah but like with the little strap i'm
like i'm gonna buckle you in four times
four times a day okay well at least it's
better than bruno who literally pees
every 45 minutes that's crazy crazy um
so yes we have a fabulous show for you
guys
um i think we should you know just jump
right in right we actually have some
really good stories so without further
ado it's time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
my chest uh-oh
oh snap i had a vision raven simone came
to me and she said claudia
you must tell the world about the power
of bruce or else
you will suffer from a very severe and
deadly case
of r a d h thank you raven
i shall deliver your message to the
people of the morning toast with honor
today's episode is brought to you by
bruce which we talk about all the time
and people keep asking for the code so
here it is don't forget bruce is the
most amazing
electric toothbrush on the market i went
to the dentist two days ago and she
literally was like oh my god what kind
of toothbrush do you use
you brush so well and i'm like thanks
doc it's a brush and
if you want to know what bruce is they
clean your teeth at 31 000 movements a
minute whereas manual toothbrushes tap
out at just 300.
many electric toothbrushes are barely a
step up for manuals and some of the
electric toothbrushes on the market that
do a good job can cost over 200.
but bruce is here they deliver premier
sonic wave technology without the
markups that big electric toothbrushes
tack on you get the brush kit which is
what jackie and i both have we got it in
the millennial pink which is it's so
cute on your counter and has this like
magnetic very sleek charging station
you get in the kit it features the
toothbrush three electric brush heads
magnetic charging station and a sleek
travel case and the brush itself has
six cleaning modes daily white gentle
gum
max and tongue it has a smart timer with
a quad pacer and the battery life
lasts four weeks so if you are going to
travel you don't need to bring your
charger unless you're traveling for more
than four weeks in which case i'm
jealous
um and if you want to get 15 off plus
express
free shipping december 16th through
december 20th so if you want to get it
as a gift for someone and you might
think it's too late
it's not because that 15 off in free
express shipping
um is still valid when you use promo
code toast at bruce.com
it's guaranteed arrival before christmas
and you can try it 90 days risk free
and get a two-year warranty so the
website to get your bruce and the code
is b-r-u-u-s-h
dot com promo code toast and honestly my
doctor said i had amazing teeth so like
if you want amazing teeth
bruce i used to think that brushing your
teeth like didn't make a difference like
at the dentist you know what i mean but
she straight up was like
your teeth look so good you're a good
brusher what do you use
and she's like electric and i'm like
ma'am it's a bruise it's a bruise
get your brush get your brush on okay
first story
the biggest news of the day strangely
enough the planned lizzie mcguire
revival is officially dead at disney
plus
hillary stuff made the hillary's stuff
oh i'm like
hillary's stephanie duff i didn't know
she had a middle name hilary duff made
the announcement on instagram on
wednesday saying quote i've been so
honored to have the character of lizzie
in my life
i know the efforts and conversations
have been everywhere trying to make a
reboot
work but sadly and despite everyone's
best efforts it isn't going to happen i
want any reboot of lizzie to be honest
and authentic to who lizzy would be
today
it's what the character deserves okay i
have two thoughts on this reboot
one am i necessarily like devastated
that i won't be watching it no because i
probably
like wouldn't have watched it in full
anyway reboots are just like so pathetic
second i just find it shocking that this
particular reboot did not get
rebooted because there are so many like
shitty reboots
and of all the ideas i've heard for a
reboot like this is not the worst one
no it's really not but this is not
surprising i mean it wasn't
very long ago where she like posted on
social media to ask hulu to pick it up
so there's obviously like
a sad element there yeah drama at the
lizzie mcguire reboot and
also like i'm so anti-reboot that like
to me this was good news it's like oh
great another show that's not going to
be ruined
and can just live in our memory is like
a perfect thing you know when like
you have you heard of the mandela effect
now
it's a thing on tick tock where i mean
it's a thing in like psychology but
i learned about it on tick tock where
it's like you have these preconceived
notions in your head
and like of what things look like or
what things appear to be or what you
experienced
but it's actually not at all like if i
were to tell you
you know what the fruit of the loom um
logo looks like yeah what does it look
like
like fruit in the basket there's no
basket there's no cornucopia
oh wow that's the mandela effect it's
like everyone just assumed there was
like a cornucopia
but there wasn't and i think one of
those things is like we think that
lizzie mcguire was like this amazing
transformative show
there were literally two seasons yeah
like that's crazy
yeah and when i heard that like my mind
was blown i think of it as like
the hannah montana which was like seven
seasons like i just
i assume i looped it in with all those
other disney shows but it had
two seasons yeah but even if this was
hannah montana we were talking about
like hannah montana is that perfect
thing and like i just don't think you
need to touch perfection
or work it to the bone so that it's no
longer perfect well
that's an interesting thing you say
because
i obviously would definitely be
interested in in discussing
a hannah montana reboot but it would
only be if miley was like so fully on
board and i think she's made it very
clear she's like
no i think she's like into hannah these
days and i think she would be on board
but like
i don't want that reboot i think she's
into hannah now because hannah's music
outperforms miley's music yeah back then
and now yeah i just i don't want it i
don't want these reboots but you know
what
is looking pretty good those gossip girl
cast photos that are coming out of the
gossip girl reboot
but like but that's also different
because it's a whole new cast so it's
like
that was like when 90210 we had this yes
and
woodley that was so good woodley
shailene mcguire what's her name the
other shaylene grimes
cheney grimes they're literally the same
person i'm sorry like
crazy they look exactly like and their
names are the same i completely agree
i think my favorite fact about 90210 is
that sarah foster was in it
yeah no and meghan markle was in it oh
yes but sarah foster was like actually
in it meghan markle wasn't in it for
like once
um shit's creek was in it oh yeah sarah
foster was
everything naomi's sister yeah i can't
believe like that's sarah foster did we
talk to sarah foster about that when she
was on the podcast
i don't know we must have there's just
so many fun facts but anyway so what i'm
saying is
if there was a lizzie mcguire reboot
where it was like
um i don't know like lisa mcguire and it
was just like a different girl like
but is it the same age like same premise
same premise but like new casts
like gossip girl like 90210 i'm i could
be more here for that but to like
bring these characters into their old
age like it's a little sad
it's a little sad but there are like
very few examples of
super successful reboots i think fuller
house is probably the most successful
one like people
love it i've watched a few episodes it's
actual trash but
people seem to i don't know what's going
to be without lori laughlin but
people seem to love it and it's on like
their fourth season now and that's
because like they didn't bother having
all the people they took the ones who
were kids on the show and they grew up
and now it's like
it i think it was well done in the sense
that it's really full circle it's like
now dj is a mom
you know yeah i mean i can speak to
whether or not it's well done because i
haven't watched it well it's successful
because it hasn't been canceled then
it's
on it's like fourth oh it's ending okay
great great great great great um
reboots that i do watch i don't watch
any
i don't think that i watch any but it's
a novelty so them having like six
seasons
is unnecessary because it's like you
watch it once like to see your
characters back together but then to
watch them like go back to work it's
just sad
it's just that and also like i just feel
as though lizzie mcguire would grow up
to be
um kelsey from younger and that show's
already being made redundant
if they want to go into kelsey's
backstory and her real name is lizzy and
she like went to
italy and she dressed and like and she
was a pop star sure
yes sure yes i'll take that because you
know the whole younger
story line is getting kind of older by
the way 100
yeah so i don't know i just don't think
this is like very sad news
or shocking because there was so much
drama on the set and then lizzy pleading
on instagram
it was just messy from the moment it
started yeah i'm just like
i'm okay with this but i know a lot of
people aren't and i
i i'm sure you're going through it right
now and i know i think you're okay
i think you're okay disrespect that
people might have wanted the reboot no
like i'm sure people wanted the reboot
but you know what you guys it's gonna be
okay like it was only on for two years
anyway and we were like
11 years old yeah the mandela effect is
like something i'm currently obsessed
with
nice current obsessions okay next up a
little food news
allison roman won't return to the new
york times after the chrissy teigen
drama
allison roman announced she will not
return to the new york times after
taking a break from the gig
following her controversial comments on
chrissy teigen she wrote on instagram on
wednesday
feels like a good time to formally
mention i won't be returning to new york
times cooking
i'm proud of the work we made together
but excited for this new chapter which
includes more recipes
videos and writing over on a newsletter
letter and beyond
writing over at where a newsletter
that's called a newsletter i believe
because the a is capitalized there has
been the n is capitalized
got it this year there has been so much
food drama like
this and then there was like all this
drama with bon appetit and i don't
follow but i just like saw people
talking about it and it's like
the food world is cr for lack of a
better word crumbling
my chest that was a good punch my chest
um i don't care like i don't care i'm
not like big into the food world but she
posted this news alongside a recipe of
like this
anchovy shallot pasta disgusting that
was no but like that's the point
it's a number one recipe from like new
york times food for the whole year so
like that's really what people are
making this year at home and apparently
it's like you use the whole can of
anchovies
and it's still good so sick but like
that's the point that's people are so
disgusting
anyways i just so uncivilized i feel
like i wish i
tried that pasta this year i feel like i
still can i know i just feel like i
wasted so much of quarantine like just
making chili like
making jelly chili
we started making chili like a month ago
no i started making chili
well in the beginning of quarantine i
feel like i could have stepped outside
my comfort zone a little bit
and i feel like everyone was making like
shallot pasta
and i was just like heating up you know
chicken plant-based chicken nuggets yeah
no i have no regrets about what i
decided to cook in quarantine because i
didn't go for the sardine pasta
but i did really um
cultivate my craft of spaghetti
bolognese and taco and that's like my
two favorite meals so i have burgers
no i mean i just said that pasta looks
really good and i'd like to like do
something other than pasta and cottage
cheese or
rayos oh i love rayos um sorry for
allison roman that she's
like she's such a household name at this
point which i learned like because due
to her controversy
to this drama and so i feel like she you
know could become like
an extremely she already is but on her
own a very influential
food news they're always looking for new
folks over at food network yeah i feel
like
there's so many opportunities in the
food world and i think her brand is on
point and
people love her recipes and a bunch of
people left bone appetit this year
right so i think i heard they're hiring
the food world is really being shaken up
yeah just like your salad but i feel
like
i've actually been in the mood this is
weird to watch like cooking shows like
traditional
cooking shows i'm so glad i am so so
glad you brought that up
and so every once in a while when i'm
like just wanting to watch live tv like
i don't want to have to go to one of the
streaming services and i'm like i want
to watch the food network like i want to
watch like sandra lee two shots
like i want to watch rachel ray every
single time i turn on the food network
it's a competition cooking show
i was just having this conversation with
someone
they don't [ __ ] put on cooking shows
anymore it is all competition
guys grocery games cupcake wars there's
no more 30 minute meals at home with
sandra lee
artie's party like where are those shows
of people just standing in their kitchen
cooking i could not
agree more those were iconic and even
though you were never going to make the
recipes there was something so soothing
about just like watching people cook and
also like i just want to watch other
people
cook to learn like small techniques that
i don't already know like
i'm not going to like write down the
whole recipe and copy it on the tv mrs
doubtfire style no they put it on the
blog so
right but like she was watching tv and
doing the recipes yeah i don't think i
would do that but like
watching how they do like chop certain
things might just give me a skill that i
didn't already have and i feel like i
would find it really soothing
also they always have these like holiday
cupcake things on
i'm like oh i'll watch it because i like
the grape the competition yeah i like
the great british bake off so
it must not be that dissimilar like no
shade to these bakers like
it's really bad yeah i know the stuff
that they do it's like it's real amateur
hour and i feel like
maybe i feel like they've ran out of
like that's like talented bakers
yeah because it's been on for so long
when they first started they got the
best in the country and then they like
started to lower their bar
and now it's like honestly i could do it
yeah no it's just like not that
impressive
no i know it's like mean to say i do
like those like
halloween cake wars where you like make
the scariest ghost house
and that's cool but i agree i'm really
upset with the programming shift they
i don't think i don't even know one i
think they still put on barefoot
contessa sometimes
but i would love to watch her yeah
controversially she's not my absolute
favorite in terms of watching them cook
my least favorite was always giada de
laurentiis but i would even take that i
really loved 30-minute meals with rachel
rachel
ray's iconic i'm finally at a point in
my life where i can appreciate this
content and i never watched it before
and it's like now i'm finally here and
the trainers left the station yeah no
we're so late like it's so crazy i'm
sure it's because like competition shows
just perform so much better yeah
um but i don't know i just i feel like
there's a gap in the
in the market iron chef like i'm so over
these competition shows beat bobby flay
there's so many
i just feel like throughout the day time
there should be like the shows that you
watch at home
yeah and then at night like we could
spice it up with some competition well
so there's also the cooking channel
which i believe is owned by food network
because they like share a lot of talent
and debbie mazar has her show on their
[ __ ] and kitchen um
i wonder if that maybe is like where
that programming went i've never watched
i know it's one channel up
for me from food network maybe i don't
know i just
all i know is i've been disappointed too
many times and so i had to bring it up
i'm so glad you brought that up because
that's crazy you've had the same
thoughts i don't know who i was just
with but i was literally talking about
how it's like so frustrating
that every time i go i like get the itch
i go and it's like never what i want
it's always guys grocery games
supermarket sweep like yeah
maybe they're on like a streaming
service but again that's like no i don't
want to have to like come into it i just
wanted like background
yeah i'll even watch commercials like i
just i want the relaxed rachel ray
and i loved that kitchen she used to
work out it was like very retro do you
remember
yeah it was like all kind of like smeg
inspired yeah she would
that was my favorite show i remember
like watching that growing up i love
rachel right i should watch her daytime
talk show you should
she's a queen i think she's she's really
successful she's so rich i have her um
baking trays they're wonderful i know i
burned my finger on it yeah well that
was on you
100 i don't blame rachel literally said
don't touch it right out of here i'm not
suing i'm not
an epic no i mean i would i did suffer
you know
three degree burns their third degree
burns anyways if anyone's listening
please please help us where can we find
those shows yeah okay
ready for our next story yes it's a
little new year's eve news
because the plans have been announced
for new year's eve in times square and
it's the first time since 1907
that the ball will drop without
spectators and i'm just curious what
happened in 1907 that there were no
spectators none of the articles
influenza i don't know spanish flu they
haven't said
wow they're just like saying 19
depression no those are the 20s
yeah no so world war one
no that's like the teens oh it is yeah
so anyways just that's a fun fact about
1907 but also
no spectators at the new year's rockin
eve and gloria gainer will be performing
i will survive
um i just have to okay that's like in
poor taste um no i feel like it's
meant to be inspirational no it is but
like the year that people
so many people died from a disease and
we're like i will survive it just seems
like
and the year that so many people
survived from the disease okay and the
company
okay gloria whatever i just seem it just
seems like we're living in such
sensitive times i'm just shocked that
didn't get tabled
immediately yeah no really and they just
have to say
um they can try to keep people out of
times square
just like they tried to keep people out
of the rockefeller christmas tree
lighting did you see what happened
oh my god they literally put up huge
like 18 wheeler trucks around
rockefeller center so even if you were
standing like you couldn't see inside
pete there was like one gap between two
trucks
a million people like came just to take
pictures
so and new york time i mean times square
is so much bigger so they can try but i
i have a feeling people will who want to
will
make their way over there oh wow i
didn't even think that people would like
want to go you cannot stop a drunken new
yorker like
pandemic come hell or high water like
they're going
yeah oh wow that'll be interesting and
then of course you can watch it on tv
so sticking oh
1907 was the first ball drop and they
didn't let people come see it
like that seems like kind of selfish no
they're saying
since 1907. well then then this the
headlights should be
times square ball drop will drop without
spectators for the first time ever
right not since 1907 right you know what
i mean
100 100 maybe that was the year it
started but then i should say first time
ever 100
100 you know 100
so balls have been dropping since 1907.
um
this is like sad you know this is
another thing dick and rock and clark
and rock and eve
um i that's like a memory from like
the time that i was born and you see the
people and you're always like i want to
go there and then you grow up and it's
like why the [ __ ] would i want to go
there
yeah i always wanted to like be in times
square and then it's like you grow up
and you realize what it actually entails
and then you're like i want to perform
there yeah oh yes
just kidding i have no talents no you
could um
i could you would be like everyone else
we could be like andy and anderson
100 that's a good dream actually i
happen to think that andy and anderson's
um
new year's eve is like maybe one of the
best one out there like they're so funny
and i meant to bring this up yesterday
because two nights ago i watched
anderson on watchtrap and live with
kaylee cuoco
talking about the flight attendant and
it was just so funny and he was so
relaxed and he's always i feel like
very uptight on what shop inside like
about time people getting their answers
like it all running smoothly and i think
it actually like affects his performance
yeah like he doesn't listen to the
answer because he's like it's this
answer
he's on his car yep um but he was so
relaxed with anderson
and it was like such a good vibe i loved
seeing andy in that way and that's what
they do on new year's eve and i feel
like they're so funny i remember a few
years ago it was raining
and they're like on these they're like
in sky boxes so they're like kind of in
the air
um it was raining and they were wearing
umbrellas and like
um they were you holding umbrellas and
they like the tv association like
called them when they were on commercial
break was like you can't use an umbrella
it's like a fire hazard if it falls off
the thing it'll
hit someone in the face and andy and
anderson took their umbrellas down and
were getting like poured on
and they're looking around all the other
sky boxes of all the other broadcasts
going on like
everyone is using an umbrella and it was
just so funny i feel like they do a
really good job and i haven't watched
dick
clark rock ryan seacrest in so long
um i just feel like it's not it it's
time to bring in the big guns
anderson and andy i think oh i i watched
a little bit of them and i had the
opposite thought
really i thought it was like so what you
thought was like candid about it i
thought was like super messy
oh that's what i love though yeah i
don't know they like conferenced in like
lindsay lohan and then oh that's what
the no no but like there was like the
wi-fi was horrible like it was
is this how much i was glad you're
saying or on new year's year's eve
but i don't know maybe i'm just
misremembering um
also i think that the historical
significance of like it being kathy
griffin and then like kathy griffin like
coming for andy cohen's neck and all
those videos like that to me as a pop
culture enthusiast like
i have no choice but to be exciting it's
exciting okay well next up speaking of
celebs we have the highest paid
celebrities of 2020
according to forbes judge judy no okay
let me think
number one highest paid salary man or a
woman woman
kylie yep number queen
queen at 590 million dollars in 2020. is
that it like in salary
in paid wow that's crazy number two wait
sorry do they give
what it's from like endorsements um
she well because of cody right and
because she sold kylie cosmetics got it
okay so i guess
would kim be next no okay so number two
is man or woman
man give me the industry music
i mean he would have a hard time just
nailing it down to one
red seacrest no because it's just
i feel like he doesn't really put
himself in any boxes can you give me
more clues
he's very has a hand in everything
ryan's across no do you think more like
metaphysically
tony robbins no you're getting closer
sort of yeah like
culty vibes i mean no karen cruz
who my chest kanye oh oh same family
yeah
yeah yeah three four and five wait
that's crazy that the top two on forbes
come from the same family i know
are three four and five any kardashians
no all athletes okay who are they roger
federer christian ronaldo lionel messi
okay number six kim no
number six chris no not a kardashian
number six could be man or woman man we
announced this year that he became a
billionaire
industry entertainment elon musk elon
musk okay he just became the second
richest person i'm sorry
sorry sorry sorry and mars okay billy we
announced this year that this man became
a billionaire
and and we were so happy for him yes
it's all coming back
we were so happy for him and why were we
happy for him because he's a precious
gem of a man like
always doing like the best
good work lifting people up remind me
tyler perry
oh yes so happy for him um and i'm glad
that he's using those funds to pay carl
lentz's rent
yes exactly seven neymar another athlete
eight okay the eight is big for the the
broadcasting
hosting world joe rogan no but that's a
good guess similar
but bigger established who's more
established than joe rogan
it's right there it's right there alex
cooper
who howard stern
i got so fixated on podcasting i forgot
about radio yeah yeah
nine athlete man
lebron yeah oh my god i'm so smart 10
actor man movie star
former athlete arnold schwarzenegger
no that's a good guy it's the rock oh
man are you okay with your chest no i'm
really not cause you're like not
laughing at any of my jokes
it's so hurtful no if i touch my chest
it means it's funny
okay okay it's like american sign
language yeah
so those are your top 10 highest paid
celebrities of 2020 who was number 10
um the rock oh right do you want some
more i could just like i'll just rattle
them off instead of this guessing game
i was having fun but sure 11 rush
limbaugh
12 ellen 13 bill simmons also ellen
sorry really
bill simmons podcasting yeah yeah
because he sold his network
the ringer yeah and to spotify
who do you sell to spotify um so ellen
like put out this video just like
updating everyone like on how she's
doing and honestly like
i really felt bad for her like she's
just
she's a woman defeated like she's
she was just so down like yes because
she had coveted but like i just think
she knows like
like her time is up you know what i mean
like everyone's just like over her it
was just like such a sad video to see
her
like this powerful woman just be i feel
like if she thought everyone was over
her she wouldn't put out a video talking
about her coveted symptoms
i feel like she had to you know because
like that's just the world we live in
now she was and she was like i'm totally
fine 100
they don't tell you about the extrusion
excruciating back pain she was just like
tell you about an
oc real housewives of both seats that's
true she was just like trying to be
funny and like relatable and it was just
it was so flat and the video like for
the first time in this whole ellen
debacle like
i i felt a lot of sympathy for ella okay
and not so much because she had cobid
but just because her spirit was
was crushed i understand and then she
was like trying to be funny like playing
connect four with porsha and it was just
it was soul crushing it really was chest
chest touch 14 elton john
happy for him 15 james patterson the
novelist but you might know him from the
jeffrey epstein documentary which is
so underrated so weird i thought you
were going to say you might know him
from his commercials like
every book he makes has a commercial for
somebody you know he's james patterson
yeah and then he's like walking the
beach in the upstate documentary because
he was his neighbor
yeah because he lived in palm beach yeah
well that's actually you know what that
reminds me of
um and i think it was i'm so glad he put
it in his um stand-up routine
when dave chappelle did the whole thing
on r kelly and he was like i'm not a
betting man but if i were like r kelly
definitely did that [ __ ]
and then he was like and i have this
friend dream who's the documentary
filmmaker and she made
the lifetime documentary and she was
like chappelle do you want to be in it
and he was like
no and then dream when she was doing
press was like
um dave pal said no to being in the
documentary and of course like everyone
picked that up
and dave chappelle was like i only said
no
because i don't know this man at all
never met him and that
now it's like a trend of like
celebrities being put in documentaries
when they've literally never met the
person they know nothing about but it's
like because they're celebrities
no and they have an opinion on the
matter like they're an expert james
patterson
yeah no but he lived so and he's i don't
i don't think it's the same thing so 16
steph curry
17 ariana grande 18 ryan reynolds wait
where's taylor swift on this list
she's not here no what year is this 2020
the one that we're in
i guess she really she might be later
down
19 gordon ramsay 20. i think this is the
most shocking one
the jonas brothers whoa 68.5
million dollars but how did musicians
make money in 2020
album sales merchandise licensing deals
i guess um taylor's number 25 on the
list is 63.5 million
but like the chain smokers are 21.
well how much 68 million
dr phil is 22. happy for him
ed sheeran's 23 kevin durant's 24
taylor's 25
tiger woods 26 kirk cousins 27
post malone 28 jk rowling 28
also ryan seacrest 28 also they all made
60 million
fabulous i'm happy for all these people
slightly jealous but still happy
yeah still happy jealous very very
so jealous so just interesting what the
celebs were up to who was making money
in 2020.
wow this list is really interesting like
sean mendes 54.5 million well he had a
netflix documentary so i'm sure that was
like at least 20 mil
you think so yeah and i think his tour
and he grossed 87 million dollars on
tour
in 2019. and that's how the jonas
brothers made a lot of money too their
tour
but in 2019. so this is the the list
from
money they made in 2019 you know i don't
know how
it goes okay you know because um it's
the 20 20 list but like some you know
maybe
you cashed the check in 2020 yeah i feel
that i find it interesting though that
like everyone's been suffering this year
but it seems like celebrity culture is
like alive and well and they're still
making lots of money
um and i'm happy for them yeah i mean
this is like a list of like literally
the biggest people on earth and
so like smart and respected
intellectuals and kylie is number one
and that's just everything to me and
and i know that's like why people hate
her but that's why i personally
stand for life like stand for life she's
not just on the list like number one
above kanye like that's crazy crazy
above james patterson so prestigious
um all right now because i know we have
one more story
yeah that's not the fifth and final
story because the fifth and final story
is the fact that dorinda medley is
selling sonya by swinging morgan dresses
on poshmark dressed one dress a used
certainly by
sony morgan dress yes rony fans might be
dying to get their hands on a dress
designed by sonia morgan but now they
can get it straight from dorinda's
closet
jorinda recently added a black balloon
sleeve dress from estonian by sony
morgan line to her
poshmark page and is selling the 200
style for 175.
that's not enough of a discount for a
used dress
yeah um normally like i don't really
report on
former housewives doing stuff oh is that
like a
principal personal preference yeah but
you wanted to talk about this because
i saw also somebody left a comment on
our instagram that in addition to
selling estonia by sonia morgan used
dress
jorinda is also selling a used lady gang
piece of merch
yeah so justice for the lady gangers um
i i always feel like when we get to a
point with the former housewife
shelling things on poshmark it's always
dark you know um and this reminds me of
when carol roswell was let go from
housewives she was selling used
underwear on
lingerie but which is on which is
stuff that you put on your fancy
underwear yeah yeah she was selling it
on poshmark and i just feel like i
i agree i don't necessarily need to keep
up with former housewives but
i was really interested especially in
new york as it pertains like the women's
finances
related to the show and that's why like
they're so dependent on it and i think
dorinda was a prime
example of that she moved out of her
apartment she's now fully in the book
berkshires and um her instagram is just
getting weirder and weirder oh i don't
follow her but she's fully in the
berkshires i really like that for her me
too her house and berkshire is so nice
um did you see uh this video that i sent
you
about i started to watch it but
underwritten
instagram i started to watch it but then
i i couldn't give it more time than i
did
okay because i thought it was a joke but
then it wasn't and if you haven't
watched it during the put up this video
on her instagram
um that hannah her daughter did like
this fashion styling
video and i just think everyone should
see it and that's all i'll say okay
i think that's really like that's good
um
all right housewives recap let's start
in order oc
i thought it was a great episode i'm not
gonna lie i need to go to lake arrowhead
i know and that house was cute at first
but i agreed with kelly like the longer
i looked at it
uh serial killer vibes it was nice from
the outside and
the big decks over the lake are like the
nicest part but the house inside was
like a little scary i mean and then the
bugs and the spiders like i'm out that
was insane and of course it's like
literally the one time gina gets the
master like i thought that was so funny
and i know i'm very hard on gina
she's been good i have to say two things
she was great this episode she had the
most
um incredible moment which i'm gonna get
to in a second and two her hair looked
awesome yeah it was her natural hair
blown out and i was just
happy to see it yeah and i have to give
her credit because they had that
you know kind of awkward uncomfortable
conversation between bronwyn and kelly
just talking about like
the state of the world and the black
lives matter music movement and some of
those like historical
um statues coming down and it was
getting really tense
and i kind of wish that they had like
had a more civil discussion about it
because it might have been like more
interesting but then they were just like
being messy
but then gina just stepped in and first
of all sat like
simmered the argument and said the most
poignant thing that i just was like so
impressed by because she was talking
about she got arrested
yes what was it like a year ago and of
course she was like terrified because
she was like scared about her kids but
never once did she think that the police
officer was ever going to hurt her she
was never afraid of the police officer
she was afraid of her own actions and
the consequences
and that if she were a black woman or a
black man like that would have been so
different
maybe it would have been different and
the fact that if it's a maybe it's yeah
like i just thought
i never expected you know and all of the
shows we're watching now covering the
black lives matter movement i never
expected
gina to say what i thought like to be
like the most poignant thing like
she just didn't expect it from her and
she really shut the conversation down
and i'm i can't believe what i'm about
to say but like jean is a queen
yep she she has queenie vibes queenie
vibes are
emulating all around yes i agree and i
just
i like that moment but she said that in
her confessional
and i just thought it was a very pr like
profoundly she said the second thing in
her confessional saying if it would have
been different if she was she talked
about her experience getting rest and i
love you know when people pull on
personal experiences especially ones
that might have been traumatic
and i just thought it was brilliant like
really brilliant um
and speaking of queenie vibes as it
pertains to gina elizabeth vargas is my
queen
and i absolutely love her and i feel
like she and kelly and gina are like
having the best time on this trip and
bronwyn bronwyn shouldn't have been on
this trip and to be honest like
bronwyn's presence on this season in a
lot of different scenarios
is kind of like polarizing yeah but
here's what i don't like about bronwyn
like last week when everyone was getting
together to talk [ __ ] about elizabeth
she's like the big
dog on campus like she's she's literally
hosting the gathering
talking the most [ __ ] you know like
laughing haha when is my season this
that
and then she goes to this weekend and i
don't know her like sidekicks aren't
there to back her up and all of a sudden
she's like
cowering and has nothing i don't want to
talk about shannon when she's not here
no and it's like she's one person when
she has like people behind her and then
she's another one she has to stand on
her own
yeah and i just thought that was like a
really [ __ ] lame thing that was
season one
spineless yeah like i agree it was
lame when she literally did what i she
talks like big [ __ ]
yep when everybody's around echoing her
but then like she can't
have those same thoughts and feelings
when the the odds aren't in her favor
i know and i felt like badly because i
was very sympathetic to her like
she shouldn't have put her she shouldn't
have gone on that trip like with kelly
and elizabeth like they weren't even
trying but if she didn't go on that trip
then like she's even even bigger coward
it's like wow you can't even be in the
same room as the people that you talk
mad [ __ ] about
i know without like shannon there to
back you up yeah i feel like
bronwyn got herself in a really bad
position because she
is being so open about her journey on
sobriety and her marriage and it's just
like it's really hard for her
but then she's also starting so much
drama and she's really being such a
little potster that she has to show up
to everything where it's like if she was
just
you know taking her journey to surprise
taking it easy this season
we i wouldn't have cared she didn't need
to go but she needs to answer for her
sins to elizabeth yeah like if you're
going to start digging up paperwork
which like
you didn't have to do that then you got
to show up and you have to answer
nobody asked you to do that but i also
really liked how elizabeth and i feel
like housewives never do this where she
was like we were having a good time so i
just didn't mention it like i feel like
that's something that i would do it's
like not everything needs to be
confrontation
on the show it does and i'm sure she
will bring it up eventually but it's
like
it didn't need to be the first thing out
of her mouth i agree but i'm i'm
eagerly waiting for her to take the
doors down take
bronwyn down like it really bothered me
that she did that
elizabeth has been nothing but nice to
all of these women and the fact that
like they just don't understand her
personal situation
required them to like go and investigate
like that's [ __ ] up and i didn't like
that and that's mean girl [ __ ]
yeah it really is and the trip like when
they were
on the beach like paddle boarding it
literally looked like the worst
housewives trip
of all time i couldn't agree a group of
women like who did not want to be
together in the middle of a pandemic
when like everyone should just be home
with their families like
it was so like random yeah kelly
is like the worst for so many reasons
especially as it pertains to bronwyn's
sobriety
um like she just can't help herself and
they're she's just being awful
but kelly is reality television gold and
here's why
she is on facetime with shannon madore
talking
incredible [ __ ] about bronwyn and has
absolutely no idea that bronwyn is
standing right in front of her no like
i was so like i was like looking up look
i was like no stop make a stop please
stop
it was [ __ ] terrible like but that's
why she's hilarious
hilarious and it's not like that when
that happened she wasn't like oh my god
i'm so sorry she's like oh bronwyn's
here she walked away
gotta go like i was so shocked whenever
they kept going back to oc i was like
depressed and like i really wanted to
stay in like arrowhead
but i thought was what emily was going
through was so interesting
um first of all like i felt so bad for
like even before they took shane to the
hospital like
she is she's exhausted her husband is
really really sick she's taking care of
him
all while taking care of how many kids
do you have three or two three
three little kids like i felt really bad
for her and then it's like and you have
to think of the time like
now it's like kobe we've lived with it
for so long we know more about it it's
not as scary but like
when this is happening like this is peak
you know confusion
peak pandemic and she had to drop her
husband off at the hospital he's like
texting her like he's like
it's like an every hour it's like a
fight to survive i felt so bad for her
and emily's my queen and i
was sad that she couldn't go on the trip
and then things just went downhill so
fast
yeah my queen yeah i was praying for her
no it was very sad but
knowing that it turns out okay is it
okay yeah
um and i do think it's crazy that
shannon like
didn't get it so far no right so far i
don't know if she ends up getting it
but in this moment in time she doesn't
her and john don't have it
yeah also i guess next week like she's
starting to like she's now
mad at her kids because they got it and
made her go quarantine with john and
they're like annoying each other and she
thinks she's going to lose her
relationship
because like john's tired of her yeah
which is like one don't blame your kids
for that but two that's like a very real
like
issue of course i was actually doing the
same thing they were like sitting around
all day just like
not you know just it's not like the best
situation like you never want to feel
that way when you're like and the house
looks small
yeah yeah so i was like wow don't these
people like get sick of their new
boyfriend no i don't know how people do
it
so it's it looks like she'll be talking
about that next week but shannon like
should be mad at her kids
for like if if ben
or someone in my home had like an
autoimmune disorder it was like very
high risk
you take incredibly different
precautions than you do when you're two
young people who are
knock on wood like relatively healthy so
the fact that like her kids were like
running out and partying while living
home with their mom like was
irresponsible and she should be mad at
them
for that not for john yeah she's mad
about the wrong thing
yeah no i think she was mad about that
like last week
and now next week it looks like she's
like mad that she's in this situation
because of them where she has to spend
so much time in close quarters with him
and like
it might put a damper on their
relationship yeah um but all in all i
thought it was actually a pretty
interesting episode
especially as it pertains to like
covering what was going on in the world
that at the time when
with kobe like sometimes i find those
like flashbacks like in southern charm
and all these shows to be like a little
traumatizing i just don't want to go
back to that place
but i thought how they did it this week
was super interesting because there was
a lot going on
yeah also when they're wearing those
face shields and they forgot to take the
the film i did that i did the same thing
and when gina was like i thought it was
frosty i literally thought the same
thing i like i didn't even question i
was like okay so it's a little blurry
yeah
by the way i literally did the same
thing and then you came to the office
wearing it i'm like jackie
there is a peel thing that you have no i
was like i love this thing so much like
i don't care if i can't see
right no totally that was so funny so so
much of it was like um
like funny and relatable in a sense and
i didn't find it so triggering this time
yes it was funny and relatable now for
real housewives of salt lake city
honestly nothing happened it seems like
we're gearing up
for um like a big sundance week next
week
but i did find it really interesting how
they keep saying lisa is like the queen
of sundance and i wanted to see her
actually at sundance like in her element
and to be honest i thought it was going
to be a joke but she was like doing real
parties that was
millions i know that was cool that wall
of like
that was cool that's like a big ass
documentary she came out
wme talent agency party like she was
legit yeah she was legit
and a lot of times unclear on what she
does is she a party planner
oh that part i don't know because she
described it and then i realized i had
tuned it out and then
oh my god and then i was like i don't
want to rewind because it came back
right after commercials yeah i don't
wind up watching more commercials
and so i was like maybe i'll catch it
next time i just think she's like one of
those ambiguous like branded event
managers yeah like event coordinator
yeah i don't think she's a party planner
but yeah she does like the brand
integration at events
she's like an event coordinator a brand
integration coordinator
lifestyle yeah um so i have
i'm struggling with salt lake city and
maybe you can help me
understand i love meredith like i think
she's a queen
but i can't really put into words like
how much i don't care about her son
period her son's clothing line with his
name written on it when his name
literally carries no weight
and three her son's fashion show like
and to be honest at first like
i think her son brooks like got a little
ahead of himself because at first he was
like funny and sassy and now he's just
straight up annoying and thirsty
no annoying thirsty and just annoying
like when he's crying because his dad's
not there and it's like
come on and i do feel bad i don't want
to like i know i love someone's
kid when meredith oh yes but no he has
inserted
like he is holding a snowflake like yeah
he is has put himself
in the race and wants to be talked about
on the podcast
well he's thirsty and yes he is cersei
and and
i think that he's very much interested
in everything that comes along with
being
a housewife including this part i agree
and i just
i was not i was not here for any of it
last night except when they were getting
ready i really wanted to
like kill the kid because he was like
i'm late i'm like you have this
opportunity get up and go pack your
suitcase
mom where's my slippers mom what are you
five years old you're 19 years old find
your own [ __ ] shoes
but then when the alarm went off and the
toilet overflowed like that was actually
funny oh my god no to me it was so
annoying like because bruno was like up
because the dog was barking
i literally had to lower my volume to
like three because bruno was like what
the [ __ ] going on no but that was so
funny and that is something that would
happen in my house like oh got a big
work opportunity
toilet overflows yeah no i felt stressed
for meredith but i just felt like
he was just not being helpful like not
taking advantage of the opportunity
and also like him crying because his dad
missed his first park city fashion show
and it's really just track suits with
his name on it like any like
uh no and it's like you i don't know
no this is what i was trying to say i
felt worse for meredith when she was
describing it because she felt so
she was yeah i felt so guilty that she
even put her son in a situation where
her his dad wouldn't be able to be there
for him but it's like
this situation just isn't it but brooks
is like a little bit of a brat because
brooks hi
you have the privilege of dropping out
of college living at home and starting
your own fashion line with like your
parents money
because your dad has to go to ohio and
start this company so it's like uh
either take take the take it all or none
of it so it's like it was just so i'm
like he's like crying
like oh other money you poured into my
fashion line and like now you can't come
it's like well he can't come because
he's working to pour more money into
your fashion line but it's like if
you're so concerned about your dad
seeing your fashion line like have a
show in the living room like this is
about everyone else
this is about like the world the city
seeing it the exposure like
it's not about mommy and daddy no a
hundred percent like and that's
and that's like a telltale sign like
maybe you're not ready for a fashion
line because all you
care about is your chest okay all you
care about is like your dad not like the
buyers
yeah like you're not caring about the
buyers i don't work in fashion but i
actually briefly did and i know that
it's all about the buyers it is and it's
like yeah i don't want to like go too
hard on him no like joke because he's
cute he's funny
where he's like gluing on the like
labels and he's like sad about his dad
i'm like get to a [ __ ] morning no
park city bathroom
you know and i have to say we always
rail on like obscure cities having like
their first annual fashion week like oc
when it was on a boat was like so
pathetic like i
literally could have cried myself to
sleep but who was it that started
yelling
that random woman kevin kelly kelly got
into it
because this this woman kathy who's like
a mom she was like coming for the kids
yeah she was coming for the kids
that was crazy um but i have to say like
of all the sad fashion weeks we saw even
like at new york fashion week
when some of the new york housewives and
beverly hills housewives go and it's
really sad
park city's fashion week didn't look so
terrible i have to say i didn't compare
to some of the other things that we've
seen but it actually compared to kyle
and she
actually got me thinking about fashion
weeks in general and i think that like
the real house
fashion the real housewives franchise is
absolutely destroying fashion weeks
around the world
globally i couldn't agree more because
now the phrase
fashion week is just it's so cringy
it's tacky because it's like it's kyle
and cheetah
yeah no it's it's everything it's a boat
it's brooks like
now it's like housewives kids like
bronwyn's kid was a designer
now they're all modeling and they're all
designers like it's pathetic
it's pathetic um but back to like the
other 95
of the episode it was kind of boring
like honestly nothing happened when he
had that party for
her and that's so fun so me too
like she's so sweet is so sweet she
loves so husband
she's so positive she like will
be a good friend to jen while also not
talking [ __ ] about mary like get you a
friend who can do both she invites you
over for like a tequila and hot tub
night like is that what they do in utah
it was just it was beautiful it was
beautiful i really think that whitney
was like the mvp of the episode
heather is really getting she's so
[ __ ] up together like when they went
to get drinks and like whitney was just
like being the biggest cheerleader and
heather was being so honest and heather
was like every time i go for it like my
hand gets slept and when he's like keep
going like yeah
it was just so cute but gen shot was on
um watch robin's live and she said the
next morning heather showed up with the
dudes like they obviously like got it on
and i was just so happy for heather
oh my god that's really great i love
heather the um
introduction of the vanderpump rules
cast was like weird
and i'm not sure why they were there
like there was no drama but they were
just there i enjoyed it
but i think they were just like at
sundance actually right
and then there was maybe like one of the
producers like works on
rules and they just went to the party
and i enjoyed it yeah we do
yeah jen shaw like has to start throwing
parties at other places
yeah but but the parties that were in
last night's episode like were legit the
party for whitney's husband like that
house was so [ __ ] nice stunning
stunning
shaw's party looked lit as hell like
these are real parties not like sad
like what we've gotten to in like new
york of what a party looks like
is like the eight people in a room and
like mindy
mis what's her name misty like the
housewives like a friends of house i was
like barbara like
it's always like the same rag tag and
then like a bunch of gays like it's
always the same group of people and it's
never like an organized event it's
always like an empty event space with
like a balloon
a hundred percent so i agree this was
like a dynamic party with different
people from different walks of life
lots of men women like there was just a
lot of people there was just like people
there were straight men straight women
they need to be there and don't work for
the cast members
totally it was yeah they're not on the
payroll like exactly and they haven't
been to every event on the season so far
yeah this was just like people in town
start looking closely at new york like
everyone who's in the background of
every party
they're paid extras no they're at this
like no they're like the publicist
and the yeah yeah no i know what you
mean yeah
it's like literally the housewives and
their crews and their crews
so it's all the crews in one yeah it's
sad
yeah but these parties are not sad like
they're very legitimate and yes and
heather found a man
and heather yeah and that's why it's
like i think these new york parties they
can never find a man because first of
all the only guys that are there are the
they're gay friends and the straight
guys are there's a scarf guy and it's
the same two guys
that guy and harry yeah she was like why
don't all the new york women only [ __ ]
the same guys it's like because they're
the only guys who show up to the parties
yeah
yeah so i'm so happy for heather so
happy for her no it's it's still just
it's so enjoyable and in terms of jen
shaw and mary
i'm um i'm turning more towards jensha i
think
there was a few things that mary like
didn't said this episode that i just
found to be unreasonable
and i like she said her grandfather's
brother's daughter works for her so
they're related she's worked for her
for years but she doesn't know what she
does in her personal life outside the
tasks she does for her
yeah that was weird that was so weird
and
but i did think the conversation that
mary and jen had at um
whitney's husband's party was productive
and i hope that it's like we can
actually move on from this i know
um but i thought we were going to move
on from it at the end of the house i
know i know i'm just holding out hope
like once again that yeah that we can
really move on
yeah me too all in all it was a great
episode yeah it was
and it was a great week of housewives
yeah tonight we have southern charm yeah
that's it right yeah i think so okay
good i'm like on back to back to back
sunday monday tuesday and wednesday of
this week we all we had um
shows and two hours oh wow because
two bachelors atlanta and potomac oc and
slc so now we have just southern charm
tonight we'll be recapping it
tomorrow for our last show of 2020 you
guys
so sad that's so crazy we'll see you
next year
we hope you have an amazing day we'll
die we hope you have an amazing guy
i i plan on having an amazing die but
you just never know what can happen with
the snow and like my chest and i'm a
little sore
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast the milani morning
show where we deliver the first live
stories that you need to know every
monday friday on youtube so if you're
watching us on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcasts
can be found so that's spotify itunes
stitcher public radio i heart radio cast
box all the places so wherever you
listen to podcasts find us morning toast
leave a five star review
about how beautiful stunning and smart
we are we hope you have an amazing day
and we will see you
tomorrow goodbye
you